rappelons ici aux yeux du monde que la
laïcité chez nous n'est pas une valeur
négociable parce qu'elle permet de faire
vivre ensemble ceux qui croient au ciel
et ceux qui n'y croient pas aucune loi
religieuse ne doit s'imposer aux lois de
la république
parce que si la loi doit protéger la foi
ou l'absence de foi la foi quant à elle
ne doit jamais dicter la loi la
république ne doit plus céder
la france doit se lever c'est au prix de
cette fermeté que nous pourrons refaire
dans notre nation le grand pays de
l'unité nationale alors monsieur le
premier ministre ma question est simple
que comptez vous faire maintenant j'ai
bien dit maintenant pour éradiquer
l'islam politique et rétablir l'autorité
et la fermeté dans notre patrie le
conseil d'état a rejeté la circulaire de
votre ministre de l'intérieur qui au
lieu de s'occuper de la sécurité des
français s'appelle à de petites
manoeuvres politiciennes
le ministre avait un double objectif
premièrement pas d'étiquette politique
en dessous de 9000 habitants soit 96%
des villes et 5 4 54% des français
deuxièmement l'apparition d'une nouvelle
catégorie politique liste divers centres
qui regrouperait non seulement des liste
investie par votre majorité mais
également des listes plus ou moins
soutenue par votre parti la république
en marche pour faire simple des
candidats soutenus malgré eux en 2020
gonflé les résultats parce que votre
majorité n'est pas capable de gagner des
mairies revendiquer des victoires là où
vous n'avez même pas eu un candidat bref
opéré un coup de force démocratique
punir la france des territoires car elle
n'est pas la france macro nist jeudi
dernier j'ai vécu la pire séance de la
législature
de quoi s'agissait-il accordé 12 jours
de congé au lieu de cinq actuellement
aux parents qui ont la douleur de perdre
un enfant
il ne s'agit pas de polémiquer mais les
mots les arguments utilisés par les
membres de la majorité ont blessé
scandalisé révolte et nos concitoyens en
séance
nous vous parlions deuil traumatisme
vous avez répondu technique juridique
nous nous vous nous vous parlions pardon
d'humanité vous avez répondu droit du
travail
ce n'est pas une erreur collective
monsieur le premier ministre
c'est une faute morale de votre majorité
je vais revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
jeudi dernier à angoulême où l'on voit
le président de la république poser de
façon ostentatoire paraît d'un tee shirt
marqué l bd avec une petite illustration
un chat avec l'oeil crevé lorsque l'on
est président de la république que l'on
a investi des pouvoirs qui sont le sien
qu'on est le garant des institutions et
que de ce fait là on est le patron des
forces de l'ordre est le garant de
l'ordre public
on ne se livre pas des exercices de ce
genre cette espèce d'abandon des forces
de l'ordre qui sont les derniers
gardiens de la république à un moment où
la france ça a été dit tout à l'heure et
fracture est divisé et vit dans la peur
ministre la situation de notre pays est
grave
les crises sont profondes et elle
tranche avec légèreté dont le pouvoir
fait preuve
[Musique]